for will West constituency I Stephen
burrows being the returning officer at
the election for a member of parliament
for the rural West constituency do
hereby give notice the the number of
votes recorded for each candidate is as
follows caldera de Almeida Antonio
commonly known as caldera Tony the
Conservative Party candidate eighteen
thousand five hundred and one poin John
Bernard Karen Green Party 429 Greenwood
Margaret Labour Party twenty-three
thousand eight hundred and sixty-six
we reserved Peter Timothy Clifford
Liberal Democrat 1155 the number of
ballot papers rejected was 83 and I do
hereby declare Margaret Greenwood is
duly elected
[Applause]
thank you very much I just would like to
say a few words really I'd like to begin
by thanking the returning officer and
all of the staff here this evening
who've done things so smoothly we've had
such a smooth evening with regards the
camp I'd also like to say what a huge
honor it is for me to be reelected as a
member of parliament for we're all West
and I'd like to thank absolutely
everybody who voted for me and I will of
course do my utmost to serve every
single member of the constituency I also
would like to be a thank-you to my
agents councillor Stewart Whittingham
who has worked tirelessly and with good
humor throughout and to the tremendous
campaign team who have really we've had
an absolutely fantastic campaign and
we're always with one we've run a
positive campaign with positive messages
Labour Party mad manifesto is really
resonated on the doorstep and of course
it's been a real pleasure for me as well
to campaign alongside people who support
Jeremy Corbyn and share his vision I'd
also like to say you know this this win
which is a stunning victory for labour
here tonight would not have been
possible without all of the Labour Party
members labour supporters and the trade
union movement who have given us so so
much support so thank you all very much
thank you
[Applause]
I'd also like to up